hey steve how are you i'm doing
excellent i want to start with
congratulations on the movie i agree
with everybody else it's fantastic
thank you man so much thank you
um so i love throwing a curveball at the
beginning plenty of questions about the
movie but okay
if you could get the financing to make
anything you want what would you make
and why
i'd want to get back into this project
i've been developing when before covid
overwhelmed all of our lives and it's a
it's a
it's a project about the about freud
um i want to make a film about freud or
actually it was going to be a
multi-episodic thing about 12-part
series
and
i'll go back to it eventually it just in
the midst of covid everything sort of
stopped we didn't know what was gonna
happen next
and so i put it aside and i turned my
attention to some other projects that i
have that are smaller scale because this
takes a lot of
research time and re you know and
financing to get it going it's sort of
right at first
but that's what i like to do oh i have
so many follow-ups man that's another
for another day because that is a huge
i'm i yeah
so many follow-ups but um so jumping
into why i actually get to talk to you i
think the best compliment i can give you
about the film is that if lou and the
other surviving
members were alive i think they would be
giving you very strong compliments
because you captured their spirit with
the way you told the film and i sort of
want to talk about the way you decided
uh to tell their story on screen and the
aesthetic and the choices you made was
it how did you figure that out was it
something that you figured out in the
editing room or did you go in with that
it was you know it really was
for me it was my first documentary and
so it was true about documentaries that
you are writing it as you make it in
this way that i think for feature
filmmakers dramatic filmmakers like i am
is an astonishingly different
way of working
and
and it opens up all kinds of unknowns
and it puts you into this
this this this the kind of process
is everything and every documentary is
different and we we did have traditional
interviews with interview subjects and
we started the process with that
but then we had this incredible and
unique collection of
cinema of images
that come directly from
the bloodstream of the 1960s of this
exact time and place
that was informing this
band in ways that it's hard to find a an
a parallel to when you think of other
you know popular bands or music
being this closely connected to a
genre of of cinema a filmmaking this
specific the avant-garde films of the
60s
and so that put us in a whole different
kind of sort of temporal relationship
with material that we created and
material that we inherited
that was going to be a searching process
is how to tell the story what i what i
really wanted
was to feel like the images and the
music
were leading your experience as a viewer
and
and that the oral history and the
amazing interviews we had and they were
incredible
would have to sort of play just behind
all of that
and that was a that was a balancing
process and i think that whole
goal
is is uh
was was sort of to your question about
it wasn't something i completely could
have planned in advance i had guide
posts but then you're kind of measuring
it out as you go
uh the interview with jonathan richmond
is is fantastic and also i know that
it's he doesn't do a lot of press so
yeah what what was it like when he said
yes
it was it was again it was like hearing
mo tucker say she'd do it you know it
was just like i felt and and then people
would say how did you get jonathan
richmond to say yes to be in your movie
i mean people at motto pictures who we
partnered with on this film who had
tried to interview him for other
projects
i think um
it was the combination of timing and
that that this felt like some some
people like you know lori and
john kale and they had approved me as
the director as somebody
who they wanted to trust
the storytelling too and so it felt like
it was an occasion for to maybe
you know think twice about the normal
reasons why you might say no or or feel
resistant
um that said you know we tried to get
doug doug ewell to participate we went
back to doug again and again and again
and he just didn't want to do it
and you also understand
that it's just different times of your
life you're ready to talk about the past
and other times you're not and
we're coming out of the you know trump
era he's an environmentalist he had his
hands full with a lot of stuff he was
involved in that felt pressing and i
unders i understand that i was just
really disappointed i really wanted
doug's voice in the film
uh i can't even imagine but uh this the
answer to this but how much of a
nightmare was it to get the clearances
to use this footage because my god well
it was it was it this is where i relied
on
so many amazing people from the
beginning it was brian o'keefe one of
our archive producers my partner
who
really did the deep dive into curating
the list of avant-garde films that would
be the sort of master list that would go
into our database
then it was the amazing folks at motto
carolyn hepburn in particular who helped
us get
temp versions of all of the films to put
into the avid so that fonzie
adam and myself my two editors could all
work on our avids and
have the material at at our at hand uh
but then yes once we were getting close
to locked
pictures of the film
and this particular was particularly
difficult during covid because archives
were not being manned or housed or
staffed so
the process of going to all the various
archives and getting the best masters of
the material was and affording it
uh
that was
a and ultimately umg
who were the company that started the
whole thing by coming to me and saying
would todd be interested in doing a a
doc on the velvets
they ultimately stepped up and covered
the overages for this film so we're just
i just can't be more grateful for the
people we put around ourselves and
and the people who initiate the project
by initiating it by coming to me with it
i love learning i love
talking about the editing process
because it's the final rewrite and on a
film like this it's it's everything so
the movie's about two hours did you ever
have like a two and a half hour cut that
you were like i don't know how it's
gonna get shorter than this
you know we we were
it wasn't
it probably it began around two and a
half hours
and then it was just continuing to hone
it and you and you know when you love
your first cut you're like there's no
way i can ever make it shorter this
happens with any movie any director will
tell you this
and sometimes the decisions that you
make sometimes you go too far and you
try to get too ruthless and and bear
down too hard
on a cut
and you think oh yeah it's getting
really
you know strong because it's shorter and
faster and all that and then you realize
no you need breathing space you need
space to catch up and you need to catch
your breath and there's not a lot of
places in this movie where you
catch your breath here's the thing i
have to say though
the thing we always protected was the
first act of the film
that really takes its time in exploring
the the sources of the music and that
it's probably the most experimental
style of the filmmaking
in the film but it's because it's a lot
of avant-garde ideas that were swapping
from artists to musician to artists and
filmmaker and
musician and so forth back and forth
but um we hung on to it and it puts you
in a trance for this film and of all the
responses that we've been getting on the
film which have really been so great
even people who don't love it or have
problems with it they never mention
the first
hour of the film let's say being slow
and dragging
like that
draws you in in a way that i feel really
proud of because we always knew that was
you know that was really setting the
tone for this for this film
last thing for you because i'm out of
time as a fan of your work um what are
you gonna do next do you know
i do i work i'm making my peggy lee film
oh which is something that i've been
playing with and developing for a while
and other projects have come in
to intervene of course as they do
but um i think we're finally lining up
with all of the elements michelle
williams is starring as peggy lee
and it's an era of music i've never got
you know never been able to descend into
the jazz era and the pop era and you
know
the most remarkably
complicated and
interesting and brilliant
musical subject
um and a woman who
described the kind of sexual authority
you know for her time and place that's
pretty remarkable and set the standard
for so many female artists that would
follow
uh but also somebody who who struggled
and and uh and worked incredibly hard at
achieving that sense of effortlessness
that she depicted on stage
can't wait i'm out of time again
congratulations i hope it's a huge i
hope everyone watches thank you so much
thank you so much the event was a
pleasure cool thank you
you